greetings to all of you fellow scholars
out there this is two minute papers
where I explain awesome research works a
couple of minutes at a time you know I
wish someone explained to me in simple
terms what's going on in genetics
biology and just about every field of
scientific research there are tons of
wonderful works coming every day that we
don't know about and I'm trying my best
here to bring it to you
the simplest way I possibly can so you
know researchers are people and physics
research at the Hadron Collider
basically means that people smash atoms
together
well computer graphics people also like
to have some fun and right simulation
programs to smash together a variety of
objects in slow motion however even
though most of these simulations look
pretty good they are physically not
correct as many effects are neglected
such as simulating plasticity bending
stiffness stretching energies and many
others but unfortunately these are too
expensive to compute in high resolution
unless you have some tricks up their
sleeve researchers at UC Berkeley have
managed to crack this map by creating an
algorithm that uses more computational
resources only around regions where it
cracks are likely to happen this new
technique enables the simulation of
tearing for a variety of materials like
cork foils metals vinyl and it also
yields physically correct results for
glass here's an example of a beaten-up
rubber sheet from their simulation
program compared to a real-world
photograph it's really awesome that you
can do something on your computer in a
virtual world that has something to do
with reality it is impossible to get
used to this feeling it's so amazing and
what's even better since it is really
difficult to know in advance how the
cracks would exactly look like they have
also enhanced the direct ability of the
simulation so artists could change
things up a bit to achieve a desired
artistic effect in this example they
have managed to avoid tearing a duct in
two by weakening the paths around them
Bravo thanks for watching and if you
liked this series just hit the like and
subscribe buttons below the video to
become a member of our growing club of
scholars thanks and I'll see you next
time